[Music]
it can be that the right which lay in
wait is not present in its own proper
shape to the consciousness of the doer
but is present only implicitly in the
inner guilt of the resolve and the
action but the ethical consciousness is
more complete its guilt more inexcusable
if it knows beforehand the law and the
power which it opposes if it takes them
to be violence and wrong to be ethical
merely by accident and like Antigone
knowingly commits the crime the
accomplished deed completely alters its
point of view the very performance of it
declares that what is ethical must be
actual for the realization of the
purpose is the purpose of the action
doing directly expresses the unity of
actuality and substance it declares that
actuality is not an accident of essence
but that in union with essence it is not
granted to any right that is not a true
right the ethical consciousness must on
account of this actuality and an account
of its deed acknowledge its opposite as
its own actuality must acknowledge its
guilt because we suffer we acknowledge
we have erred
in paragraph 470 Hegel explicitly
references Sophocles play the Antigone
and he's going to bring up the character
by name he's also going to end this
particular passage with a line from the
Antigone because we suffer we
acknowledge we have erred and you might
read that and say okay well that's just
a you know typical pithy line about got
to learn from the school of hard knocks
or you know there's some things you
can't learn from books you need to learn
on the streets or experientially or
however you want to think about it
but what is going on here is not just
any sort of learning it's really we
could call this a learning of ethical
catastrophe if we wanted to coin another
phrase one is going to be happening in
this paragraph and then the paragraphs
to follow tracing back to the previous
paragraph is the working out of what
would Hegel has talked about as guilt or
shield and why does the doer the the
ethical actor bare guilt in the very
attempt to be ethical to do ethics in a
substantive way dan is what we're
working with here and Hegel is giving us
once again is kind of a lynchpin moment
a turning point where we're going to see
things coming together he's making a
contrast here as well that's very
important I put these numbers here
number one and number two two different
ways in which the doer
that's how Miller is translating Honda
labove was design right the
consciousness that is acting the
consciousness that is comporting itself
the consciousness but is doing some
purpose of action how does this play
itself out there is guilt involved we
saw that already in the previous
paragraph through the very action
through the very deed through the very
resolution of the
to us as we saw now how does that guilt
manifest itself it's not just going to
be individualized that you know he's
going to talk about that at first in
terms of something like an unconscious
guilt but it's going to be as I said a
kind of catastrophe that engulfs the
entire domain of the ethical in the
paragraphs yet to come here it's just
primarily about one side so he says it
can be that the right which lay in wait
what is the right that lay in wait the
other law the law that one construes
whether it be the human law or the
divine law is entirely lacking in any
sort of legitimacy any sort of right
back to justice any sort of embodiment
of ethics so he goes on and says it can
be that the right which lay in wait is
not present in its own proper shape to
the consciousness of the doer so it can
be that in the case of some doers that
they're not conscious that they're
transgressing another law they're not
they're not conscious they're
transgressing another power another you
might say spiritual in the sense that
Hegel is using a Geisinger entity that
has its claims not only upon us but upon
the whole social sphere that we
participate in the sphere of spirit
what's the case in that in that
situation Hegel goes on and he says it's
present only implicitly in the inner
guilt of the resolve and the action so a
person feels guilt they're not quite
sure exactly what's going on something
has been transgressed in in the terms of
the plays not just Sophocles Antigone
but tracing back to edifice as well and
then looking ahead to the to the other
Oedipus play it could be that the
character grasped there's something
wrong something afoot but doesn't have
the the ways of articulating it yet in
terms of these these laws now in the
other way the way that's going to take
us forward that Hegel
talks about he's tracking here about the
ethical consciousness he says the
ethical consciousness is more complete
and it's guilt more inexcusable if it
deliberately sets itself up in
opposition to the the other law or the
other power Hegel uses mocked here as
well and this is exactly what Hegel
takes Antigone to be doing we saw in the
previous paragraph and this has been
hinted at quite a bit in the paragraphs
before that that why there's this
conflict in this way at this stage is
that the acting person who's acting on
behalf of one of the laws one of the
ethical powers treat the other one as if
it has no validity whatsoever as Hegel
is going to say in just a few moments as
if the other law is ethical merely by
accident and we'll get into the
implications of that in a moment
so Antigone does this if we look at
Barclays plaits which you should not rob
yourself of the opportunity to read and
reread especially when looking at this
section what you're going to discover is
that Creon and the other people as well
are going to attempt to make arguments
to and take a knee and they're also
going to make threats Antigone is
following a sacred duty and that Duty is
one that which embodies the divine law
we saw much earlier that one of the key
things in the divine law is to give the
proper rights to the dead now she has
several brothers to whom who have just
died one defending the city the other
one attacking the city with the aid of
some allies brought in and the one who
is attacking the city is viewed as a
traitor now in the paragraphs coming up
ahead we're going to get a little bit of
the backstory of this but right now what
what's important is that from the
perspective
of the human law the one brother is
going to be acknowledged as legitimate
his sacrifice matters the other brother
is going to be acknowledged as a traitor
as an alien as a foreigner somebody who
attacked the city from the outside who
does not get the proper burial rites
Antigone feels that she must do this for
her brother and there's you know a lot
of discussions we could have a Greek you
know conceptions of death and funeral
rites what matters here is that she is
his sister she's equally his sister as
she is to the brother who the human law
is taking care of so she is embodying
the divine law in contrast to the human
law the human law is declared nobody
shall bury these dead they shall be laid
out there to rot to be eaten by the dogs
birds of the air which were the Greeks
was a terrible thing she goes out there
and she pours dirt upon him - you know
at least give some symbolic covering of
the earth and thereby allow his his
shade to be set at rest and this is
viewed as something that she ought to do
she ought to do it not by the human law
which was already forbidden it but by
the divine law which Trump's the human
law in doing this she is deliberately
transgressing the human law and saying
you're human law is wrong it's not
really ethical it is violence it is
wrong it's the opposite of right or
justice so Hegel goes on here and he
says if it knows beforehand the law and
the power which opposes if it takes them
to be violence and wrong to be ethical
merely by accident and like Antigone
knowingly commits the crime the deed is
a crime a crime from the perspective of
human law a deed from the perspective
indeed a duty from the perspective of
divine law so we have a conflict here
again and Hegel goes on and here's where
we get the really interesting twist that
was going to be well you know you've got
an opposition of laws and the Strad
circumstances know what's going to
happen is this was going to undermine
both laws he says the accomplished deed
completely alters its point of view once
it's done the very performance of it
declares that what is ethical must be
actual so this is a you might say
guiding I don't want to call it
presupposition let's call it a
performative assumption that is built
into action when you act you are acting
as a conscious being as a a doer
in such a way as to be asserting that
what you're doing ought to be done so
what does that mean Hegel frames this in
terms of the ethical must be actual it's
not just enough to have nice flowery
ideas in your head and intentions and
all that you actually have to do
something if you want to be ethical if
you want the ethical to be ethical it
must be made actual let's use another
example you say that you love somebody
this is one that that Sarge himself uses
much later on if you say that you love
somebody but you don't actually do
anything loving towards them you don't
love them you may tell yourself that you
love them but the ethical content of
love it has its expression in action and
actuality in changing circumstances in
making things happen in continuing
making things happen so in this case
Antigone is is acting so here we go the
very performance of it declares what is
ethical must be actual this is
understood in a universal way the
realization of the purpose is the
purpose of the action the realization of
the end the intention is the action and
it's realization otherwise again don't
talk about it and say you have an
intention if you're never going to act
on it it's not an intention it's a whim
it's a wish it's something else instead
so if we if we broaden this
then Hegel says doing directly expresses
the unity of actuality and substance and
we're talking here about ethical
substance and its actuality so what does
that mean is that the doing thereby not
become a crime not transgress the law no
here we go
here we go it declares that actuality is
not an accident of essence but that in
union with essence it is not granted to
any right that is not a true right or if
we like justice or aught or however we
want to express it it goes on and says
the ethical consciousness must on
account of its actuality and on account
of it deed acknowledge its opposite as
its own actuality must acknowledge its
guilt so what is happening here there's
you might say two stages in the deed as
it is being done as it is being planned
as it is being talked about there is the
treatment of the other law as nullified
as being ethical only by accident they
happen to be the people in charge
they're making up the rules I guess it
would be the right thing to follow them
but the divine law says otherwise so I'm
going to follow the divine law in these
circumstances what is implicitly built
into this very way of acting and
thinking the consciousness involved is
that the ethical must become actual in
doing so it does not completely nullify
the other law because the other law also
expresses the ethical and not merely by
accident the ethical has to be essential
or it's not ethical
so what are we confronted by here this
is why guilt occurs within this
circumstance as well now we come back to
this great sentence because we've
software we acknowledge we have
the suffering occurs because this other
law is not completely abrogated or
nullified and part of the suffering is
actually the guilt telling you you acted
and you acted on you know what you felt
was right the best understanding you had
of the ethical it turned out that the
ethical encompasses more than you
thought including what you thought went
against the ethical so this is a really
serious problematic here which is now
going to be dealt with in the subsequent
paragraphs
with this acknowledgement there is no
longer any conflict between ethical
purpose and actuality it signifies the
return to an ethical frame of mind which
knows that nothing counts but right but
the doer thereby surrenders his own
character and the reality of his self
and has been ruined his beading consists
in his belonging to his ethical law as
his substance in acknowledging the
opposite law the other ceases to be for
him his substance and instead of
attaining at the actuality it has become
a unreality a sentiment or disposition
the substance does appear it is true in
the individuality as his pathos and the
individuality appears is that which
animates the substance and hence stands
above it but the substance is opposed
that is at the same time his character
the ethical individuality is directly
and intrinsically one with this his
universal aspect existed it alone and is
incapable of surviving the destruction
of this ethical power by its opposite
here in paragraph
471 Hegel is now going to sketch out for
us what somebody like Antigone in
Sophocles play by the same name is doing
that is going to lead not only to their
own ruin but to the ruin of the ethical
as it's been conceived as such and how
is this going to take place think about
it for a moment the the triumph of the
ethical was through the deed for the
person acting on behalf of one of these
two ethical powers or ethical laws the
law of the family or the law of the
community the human law acting against
the other law in a point of conflict
nullifying that but then it turns out
that that can't really be nullified as a
much greater staying power it's going to
turn out here in this section that what
aligning oneself with the ethical in a
wholehearted way was supposed to provide
to the individual falls out from under
them and they are left with just their
own individuality this is another way of
expressing what Hegel was talking about
earlier in talking about the deed as
being inevitably a sort of crime so
Hegel goes on he says with this
acknowledgement now there's a lot of
German verbiage here that I want to
actually go over because the Miller
translation although it's really great
in many respects loses the thread a
little bit here he says with this
acknowledgement there is no longer any
conflict between ethical purpose and
actuality it signifies the return to an
ethical frame of mind which knows that
nothing counts but right so let's talk
about this ethical frame of mind first
this is in Germans Italy cake is finding
a frame of mind works for that Italy can
of course is ethical and remember that
this leak in this case is talking about
something that's not just you know and
by
intentions but but really sedimented
into habits into customs into mores into
the ways in which we do things this does
not mean that everything is merely a
repetition there is still room for
creativity and innovation and
interpretation but it takes place on the
basis of that right so that's key to
keep in mind now here in the first
sentence of it we want to be a little
bit more attentive Hegel talks Miller
translate this as acknowledgment on-air
Kenan this words going to show up twice
in this passage and honor Kenan if you
remember is what self-consciousness has
been seeking the entire time another
word for it recognition so there's
there's a recognition on the part of the
human subject that is taking place of
the ethical power but the human person
is also seeking recognition as well and
not finding it in this case not able not
they're not going to be able to provide
it to themselves what we get here is
well in there is no longer any conflict
between ethical purpose and actuality
the actual German here is that the vine
- fault the splitting apart into two
things of you know ethical purpose back
and actuality of your click I'd has been
alcohol burnin right this is how a bong
at work sublation transcending however
you want to think about an integration
on a higher level so there's been a
progress here a dialectical progress
that's been taking place not one that's
actually visible from the side of the
acting person for whom they experienced
this in terms of guilt and action and
anguish and conflict but we as the
phenomenologist following along with
this can see that that an out hey bong
has taken place through this this
section and is continuing to take place
really so he says this ethical frame
of mine knows that nothing counts but
right we have a return to it we saw this
in previous paragraphs this is different
than acting ethically because you're
motivated for some other end like being
healthy wealthy wise you know Ben
Franklin style or you know looking
impressive and getting power the way you
know for example de Okies did in
Herodotus's
histories you know he is a guy who
actually he set himself up as a very
fair judge in you know in ancient city
and everybody started bringing their
cases to him because he was so just and
then he used that to seize power right
we could go on and on that the ethical
if we're really acknowledging it as the
ethical we acknowledge that it takes top
priority and that means that if other
things are going to distract us from the
ethical or are going to come into
conflict with it we have to be ready to
sacrifice those and that is why somebody
like Antigone is ready to sacrifice the
laws of the city it's not like she's
just a you know malcontent who wants to
say screw you to all the laws or
something like that including you know
her own family members know she feels
that there is an overriding duty here
that she has to satisfy and and so that
is something that Hegel thinks really is
key to the ethical that is the thing
that we acknowledge again recognize
recognition playing a role we
acknowledge as having a higher priority
so what happens because of this Hegel
says the doer surrenders his character
and the reality of his own self and has
been ruined now isn't that a strange
reward for acting ethically that you
lose your own character that you lose
the reality of yourself and that you are
thereby ruined well we saw this before
for example in the virtue in the way of
the world
to really acknowledge something as a
higher priority than one's own
individuality is to take the risk of you
know what is happening here the loss of
one's own character not a character in
the sense of just simply moral character
but a sense of who one is we might say
personality that is no longer essential
Antigone if she's acting only because
she's Antigone and that's the sort of
things she's going to do like our
modern-day celebrities who are their own
brands would not be ethical it's by
acknowledging something higher than
herself that she has to go along with
that she has the risk of getting that
but you know losing that and getting it
back and he or she's not going to get it
back why because the other law the
ethical power that she originally
opposed and said is not right is not
ethical turns out to also be the ethical
so Hegel goes on and he says this
person's being consists in belonging to
his ethical law add to substance you
align yourself totally in Antigone's
case with the law of the family or the
divine law but in acknowledging notice
there's that term again acknowledging
recognition the other law the opposite
law this one the one that you began with
ceases to be for that person his
substance and instead of attaining
actuality it has become an unreality
does this mean that one law has
disappeared entirely no what it means is
that there's a slippage and unmooring
the law that was going to cover and
protect and you know provides a meaning
and ratification the validation it might
say for the person acting on its behalf
turns out not to do that what an
experience this must be one that we some
of us have had in our lives when you
commit yourself wholly to a cause and
you find out that the cause doesn't seem
to
committed itself as holy to you as an
individual you're still left with your
individuality Hegel says that what what
this person is left with is the kind of
pathos what does he mean here by pathos
a kind of suffering
that's the original term to it and
feelings he also talks about disposition
you're left with your own being your own
personality but you're no longer being
covered by this ethical law and you're
now in conflict with this other ethical
law so he says the substance does appear
as in the individuality it says pothos
and the individuality appears as that
which animates the substance and hence
stands above it so the individual is
still fully conscious but they're aware
of a kind of slippage a kind of non
coincidence between them and the ethical
at this point and as Hegel is leaving in
the background the threat the accusation
the guilt that is imposed by the other
law which turned out not to disappear at
all but to remain in full force so he
says the substance is a pathos that is
at the same time as character the
ethical individuality is directly and
intrinsically one with this his
Universal aspect exists in it alone and
is incapable of surviving the
destruction of this ethical power by its
opposite here Hegel talks about
one-eighth achill power destroying
another this is actually going to turn
out to be mutual as we'll see in the
paragraphs yet to come I mentioned that
what is taking place here is what we
might call a catastrophe of the ethical
here Hegel is sketching out how this
happens within the individual who took
the ultimate risk and who seems to have
bet on the wrong horse
perhaps they should have gone to the
other side the other law that remains to
be seen
but at the same time this individuality
has the certainty that that
individuality is pothos is this opposing
power suffers no more injury than it has
inflicted the movement of the ethical
powers against each other and as the
individuality is calling them into life
in action have attained their true end
only insofar as both sides suffer the
same destruction for neither power has
any advantage over the other that would
make it a more essential moment of the
substance the equal essentiality of both
and they're in different existence
alongside each other meanings are there
without itself in the deed they exist as
beings with itself but with the diverse
self and this contradicts the unity of
the self and constitutes our unrighteous
and necessary destruction character
likewise in respect of its populace or
substance in part belongs to one only in
part from the aspect of knowing the one
character like the other is split up
into a conscious and an unconscious part
and since each itself calls for this
opposition and it's not knowing is
through the deed its own affair each is
responsible for the guilt which destroys
it the victory of one power and its
character and the defeat of the other
would thus be only the part and the
incomplete work which irresistible
advances to the equilibrium of the two
only in the downfall of both sides alike
is absolute right accomplished and the
ethical substance as the negative power
which engulfs both sides that is
omnipotent and righteous destiny steps
on to the scene
paragraphs 472 is going to bring to a
successful close this clash or conflict
that has been taking place between the
two ethical powers or the laws the human
and the divine law and the individuals
the acting individuals who are embodying
and representing them as ethical
individuals as entirely committed to
their side and Hegel is going to talk
about a mutual destruction of these
these two laws it doesn't mean that
they're going to completely go away but
the what we could call their
substantiality their their claim to
universal validity ends up being denied
and something else steps in in in their
place the ethical is revealed in at this
point as destiny chicks'll or fate if
you like absolute right is revealed as
belonging to neither of the laws and the
ethical substance is revealed as the
negative how does this take place well
the entire thing that we've been tracing
out over the last three paragraphs on
the side of one representative turns out
to be going on with both of them so
Hegel says this this individuality has
the certainty that the individuality
whose pathos is this opposing power
suffers no more injury than it has
inflicted they're both acting in such a
way so this would be crayon and Antigone
or this would be the two brothers that
we're going to talk about in the next
paragraph and so he GLE tells us the
movement of the ethical powers against
each other
and of the individuality is calling them
into life in action because you need
individuality x' in order to make the
ethical actual have attained their true
end only insofar as both sides suffer
the same destruction we have here
something quite similar to what was
going on in the self consciousness
section really on in the struggle for
recognition and the struggle to the
death don't wait now he goes on and he
says the equal essentiality of both and
they're in different existence alongside
each other
means that they're both without itself
both of them are lacking something
both of them have individuality who lack
a substantial self even though committed
to their understanding of the ethical so
he says in the deed they exist as beings
with the self but with a diverse self
Hegel is saying that he's not trying to
say that we should all be oneself or
anything along those lines he isn't
saying that insofar as we're talking
about the ethical the self ought to be
united there shouldn't be any underlying
or irresolvable conflicts there and he
says this contradicts the unity of the
self and constitutes their
unrighteousness and necessary just
destruction character he says likewise
belongs to in part belongs to one only
in part from the aspect of knowing the
one character like the other is split up
into a conscious and an unconscious part
so each itself calls forth its
opposition and it's not knowing is
through the deed its own affair each is
responsible for the guilt which destroys
it so each one has taken on to itself
the guilt that we have been looking at
each one is acting you might say
criminally in relation to the other law
none of them are able to subsume the
ethical into themselves the ethical does
exist however and the ethical is what
remains in their mutual destruction or
you might say if we want to be a little
less dramatic about it their mutual
invalidation so he says the victory of
one power and its character the defeat
of the other would thus be only the part
and incomplete work which irresistible
advances to the equilibrium of the two
the equilibrium is to be found in
something greater something deeper so he
says the downfall of both sides is how
absolute right is accomplished full
brougt in German fulfill the absolute
right the absolute the ethical that
we've been seeking is attained in both
of these laws finding their relatives
age
you might say and the fact that they
don't encompass the ethical as they
thought that they did and neither did he
individuals who identified themselves
with them so he goes on and he finishes
by saying this is an impotent and
righteous destiny stepping on the scene
so that is where we're brought to by the
actions of the individuals not just any
individuals but individuals who have so
totally aligned themselves with the
ethical powers or the ethical laws that
they their deeds can indeed matter but
the mattering there turns out to be
relative eyes to this absolute destiny